YOU DON’T WANT TO MOVE MISSED TH
RALLYING FOR AMERICA.
THAT’S TWO NIGHTS ANGLE.
THE FIRST TIME THAT TRUMP IS
BEATING DEMOCRATS ON ACTUAL
ISSUES LIKE THE ECONOMY AND
CRIMES IS WHEN THEY START THEIR
DISTRACTION AND DEFLECTION
ROUTINE.
IT’S SO OBVIOUS AT THIS POINT,
IT’S ACTUALLY GETTING BORING.
THEY PREFER TO HAVE BIDEN HUNKER
IN THE BUNKER AS THEY PEDDLE
STORIES THAT HAVE ZERO EFFECT ON
YOUR DAILY LIVES.
>> ON HE IS NOT OKAY FOR THE
AMERICA PEOPLE.
>> CALLING HIM "NAIVE AND
DANGEROUS."
>> A LITTLE MORE THAN 6,000
SHOWED UP, FAR BELOW THE
EXPECTATIONS.
>> THE ISSUE THAT DRIVES THE
PRESIDENT MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE, THAT IS THE CROWD SIZE.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THE
WHITE HOUSE DOES NOT BELIEVE IT
IS RACIST?
>> Laura: BIDEN, OF COURSE,
DOESN’T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT HIS
CROWD SIZES.
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T DO RALLIES AT
ALL.
HE WASN’T EVEN OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC BUT ONLY TO 20 LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS HANDPICKED BY THE
CAMPAIGN.
AND IN THE ARENA, THOUGH, THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN’S SHOWED 12, NOT
6,000 IN ATTENDANCE AS WAS
WIDELY REPORTED BY THE PRESS.
11.7 MILLION PEOPLE WATCHED
TRUMP’S RALLY ON TV AND ONLINE.
HE GAVE FOX NEWS ITS HIGHEST
SATURDAY NIGHT RATING IN NETWORK
HISTORY.
THE MAIN POINT IS I THINK 20
YEARS FROM NOW, NOBODY IS GOING
TO BE WRITING ABOUT THINGS LIKE
JOHN BOLTON, RAMBLINGS, NOBODY
IS GOING TO BE WRITING ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC CROWD SIZE THAT A
SINGLE PRESIDENTIAL ALLEY.
AND NO ONE IS GOING TO CARE WHAT
NICKNAME WE GAVE TO A PANDEMIC.
HISTORIANS WILL NOTE HOW IN
2020, TRUMP STOOD UP TO DEFEND
THE GREATNESS OF AMERICA AS
ROVING BANDS OF NEO-MARXISTS
RIPPED DOWN HISTORICAL MARKERS
AND CITIES LEFT BY LIBERALS.
UNTIL THE PEOPLE HAD NO VOTE ON
ANY OF THE SPIRIT AND HOW, AS I
PREDICTED WEEKS AGO, THE
DESTRUCTION WENT FAR BEYOND THE
ORIGINAL CONFEDERATE TARGETS.
>> VIDEOS POSTED TO SOCIAL MEDIA
SHOW THE MOMENT HE WAS DRAGGED
TO THE GROUND.
HE WROTE THE LYRICS TO THE
STAR-SPANGLED BANNER.
THEY KNOCKED ON THE STATUE OF
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
CIVIL WAR JOHN GENERAL ULYSSES G
PERIOD A-1 PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
TO.
>> WHETHER IT’S CHICAGO, IT’S
DEMOCRATS, SEATTLE, IT’S
DEMOCRATS.
ALL OF THESE PLACES ARE RUN BY
20 OUT OF 20 ARE DEMOCRAT RUN.
THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
AND IF BITING GOD INCOME OF THIS
COUNTRY WOULD BE A DISASTER.
>> Laura: WE WILL HAVE MORE
LATER ON IN THE HOUR.
BUT SERIOUSLY, WHAT’S
REPUBLICAN -- WHEN YOU REALLY
THINK ABOUT THIS.
OTHER THAN TRUMP WOULD HAVE
DEFIED THE MEDIA AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO BE WITH HIS
SUPPORTERS.
I THINK YOU DID DUMB LIKE HE DID
TO SHOW THAT LIFE HAS TO GO ON.
BUSINESS IN AMERICA HAS TO GO
ON.
AND THAT THE CAMPAIGNING MUST GO
AND OF COURSE, WE CANNOT STAY
HIDDEN FOREVER AS THE DEMOCRATS
WANT.
IMAGINE A REPUBLICAN LIKE, LET’S
SAY MITT ROMNEY.
IF YOU WERE RUNNING.
HE WOULD BE SPEAKING TO YOU FROM
THE COMFORT OF HOME.
MUFFLED BEHIND HIS MASK AND
EXPOSING CLICHES ABOUT ALONE
TOGETHER.
SO IMAGINE THE ENTHRALL DOZENS
WHO WOULD TUNE IN FOR THAT.
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE ON THE
POLITICAL SCENE TODAY, TRUMP
KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
IDENTIFY, FRAME, AND WHEN THE
CURRENT CULTURE WARS.
>> THE LEFT, RIPPED DOWN A
STATUE OF GEORGE WASHINGTON.
AND IT WRAPPED IN AN AMERICAN
FLAG AND EXCEPT THE AMERICAN
FLAG ON FIRE.
DEMOCRATS -- ALL DEMOCRATS.
EVERYTHING I TELL YOU IS
DEMOCRATS.
AND YOU KNOW, WE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING.
WE SHOULD HAVE LEGISLATION THAT
IF SOMEBODY WANTS TO BURN THE
AMERICAN FLAG AND STOMP ON IT,
THEY GO TO JAIL.
FOR ONE YEAR.
>> Laura: WELL, HE ALSO
PROPERLY DEFINED JOE BIDEN FOR
WHAT HE HAS.
A FIGUREHEAD.
AND A FEEBLE ONE AT THAT.
>> JOE BIDEN HAS SURRENDERED TO
HIS PARTY.
AND TO THE LEFT WING MOB.
HE DOES NOT HAVE ANY CONTROL.
DOES ANYBODY HONESTLY THINK HE
CONTROLS THESE RADICAL MANIACS?
JOE BIDEN IS NOT THE LEADER OF
HIS PARTY.
JOE BIDEN IS A HELPLESS PUPPET
OF THE RADICAL LEFT.
>> Laura: BINGO.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SEEMS TO GET
IT.
THIS ISN’T AN ELECTION BETWEEN
TRUMP AND BIDEN.
IT’S BETWEEN TRUMP AND THE FAR
LEFT THAT CAPTURED THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
FINALLY, BY MERELY SHOWING UP IN
TULSA TRUMP DEMONSTRATED HE WILL
NOT BE CONTROLLED BY THE
FEARMONGERS.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT COVID
CONFECTIONSINFECTIONS.
IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD’VE SHUT
DOWN THE GEORGE FLOYD PROTESTS
AND DOZENS OF CITY ACROSS
AMERICA.
BUT THEY DIDN’T.
NONE OF THEM SHOULD BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY ANYMORE ON THIS
PERIOD.
UNLESS YOU ARE IN THE CROWD
THAT’S MAYBE ANTI-TRUMP.
THEY WANT YOU LOCKED DOWN UNTIL
A VACCINE IS AVAILABLE.
NO ONE IS GOING TO DO THAT.
SMART STATES HAVE SAID NO TO ALL
THAT.
MORE TESTING OF COURSE MEANS
MORE INFECTIONS, BUT NOW THAT WE
SEE THE TRUENESS OF THE VIRUS
ALONG WITH THE DEVASTATION THAT
ALL THE LOCKDOWNS CAUSED.
WE ARE GETTING A CLEAR PICTURE
OF ALL THIS.
NOT SURPRISING, THE STATES THAT
DRAGGED OUT THERE SHUT DOWN ARE
FALLING BEHIND ECONOMICALLY.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" NOTED
TODAY THAT NINE OUT OF THE TEN
STATES ARE RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
WHO DEMAND THAT THE ECONOMY
SHOULD STAY BLOCK LOCKED DOWN.
YOU CAN SEE THEM ALL LISTED
HERE.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, MICHIGAN IS
NUMBER THREE ON THE LIST WITH
21% UNEMPLOYMENT.
CALIFORNIA AT 16%.
FOLLOWED BY NEW JERSEY AND
ILLINOIS AT A MISERABLE 15%
RATE.
OF COURSE, THE LOWEST IS
NEBRASKA WHICH IS CONTROLLED BY
REPUBLICANS.
AND WAS UNDER A STATEWIDE STAY
AT HOME ORDER.
OTHER STATES THAT NEVER SAW
LOCKDOWN STILL SAW UNEMPLOYMENT
GO UP.
BUT NOW EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM
IS STILL BETTER OFF THAN THOSE
DEMOCRAT STATES I JUST SHOWED
YOU.
THEY HAD AN AVERAGE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE OF 6.1%.
WE TRUST THE PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL THE PEOPLE.
WE BELIEVE YOU CAN MAKE YOUR OWN
DECISIONS.
ESPECIALLY ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
THE STATE CAN MAKE THEM FOR YOU.
THEY WANT OPEN AMERICA TO A
FLOOD OF NEW WORKERS AT A TIME
WHEN SO MANY WERE STILL
STRUGGLING TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND LATINOS
ESPECIALLY NEED A PRESIDENT WHO
SEES THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING
AMERICANS FIRST.
AND DID NOT COME OUT THE PRESIDE
>> THIS IS KEY TO OPENING JOBS
FOR AMERICANS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED THEM.
THEY EXPECT THESE NEW
RESTRICTIONS TO FREE UP 520,000
JOBS.
CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU WILL HEAR
FROM OPEN BORDERS MEETING,
TRADITIONALLY HUGE SUPPORT FOR
PAUSES AND IMMIGRATION.
A "WASHINGTON POST" MARYLAND
POLL FROM LATE APRIL FOUND
PAUSING IMMIGRATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
INCLUDING 61% OF MINORITIES.
THEY FOUND THAT 81% OF AMERICANS
SEE MASS MIGRATION AS A THREAT
AS WE CONFRONT THE CHALLENGES
PROPOSED BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
IMMIGRATION HAWKS, LIKE MYSELF,
WE STILL WANT MORE.
HUGE CREDIT TO STANDING UP TO
THE BUSINESS LOBBY.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL RUN IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
I PROMISE.
FOR THE PAST MONTH, PRETTY MUCH
ALL YOU HAVE SEEN ON TV ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO VEHEMENTLY HATE
WHAT’S AT THE CORE OF THIS
COUNTRY PRAYED EVERYTHING WE
STAND FOR.
YOUR CNET TONIGHT IN
LAFAYETTE PARK IN WASHINGTON.
NOW, I THINK IT’S TIME THAT WE
SEE AMERICANS CLEAN UP AND SAY